so let me ask you about your rise so
when did you start like getting what do
you know the moment or the video that
got you like a lot of [ __ ] heat out
there I mean when did that happen
well I was always like stealing like my
mom's like phone back in the day like I
was second grade and I was filming like
fake commercials on my mom's phone and
like she would always get mad at me
because I was use it for memories on her
like holy fountain yeah so I feel like
I've always been making videos but the
video the sky rocketed me I guess it'd
be like my concert video it was back
when contouring was I soon you and I was
like kind of like teaching how to people
how to do makeup while contouring but
keeping like my personality and they're
all as well cuz I feeling makeup artist
these days especially back then like
YouTube there wasn't really much
personalities especially like men and
makeup there wasn't many of those either
so I was like [ __ ] I'm a boy that wears
makeup
I think I'm funny and then I just
started making videos and people found
that and then yeah I blew up from there
honestly but at the time when I was
making these videos I was private and I
was making them on snapchat and so my
friends were like [ __ ] it's and you
guys know snapchat is only 24 hours my
friend was like [ __ ] you need to put
them on Instagram and I was like oh my
gosh okay fine
but I was private so I posted them on
Instagram oh and one of my friend was
trying to show my video to her uncle I
still don't know why she talked on my
videos her I still don't but she's like
[ __ ] you gotta go off private cuz you
know I'm trying to show my buddies your
uncle and then overnight I just yeah I
went from like 1,000 followers and then
I went private I went off private and I
got 10,000 followers Wow yeah Wow I
already had like 80 videos uploaded but
no one was watching them because like I
said I was private and I think that's
unzip time I said pregnant yeah but
you're at a point now that I mean Abby
would you [ __ ] with like you know like
network TV I mean you could [ __ ] do
all kinds of oh my gosh that's so funny
you asked I thought you would never ask
yeah I'm on like an MTV show but due to
mess
[ __ ] Corona and her ugly ass [ __ ] so
we have to push it back and yeah but I'm
gonna have my own reality show it MCV
congratulations yeah I don't tell anyone
yeah doing something it's the weirdest
thing I've ever done and I never thought
I would ever be able to work with them
but I'm doing something with so you're
[ __ ] with you're [ __ ] with MPV no
you're [ __ ] with a Disney the real
corporate the real [ __ ] man I have a
question for you though bread man yes so
Bobby and I and a couple other comics we
wanted to do this you know how like back
home in the Philippines like the talent
is just teeming like no matter where you
go people are funny the new dancing we
wanted to do this variety sort of local
talent show and like the province but
get get like guests big guest judges
down like yeah because what I would what
I want to do is have you me and Jo koy
be the judges I think that would kill it
honestly it'd be our show yeah and it's
yeah he's [ __ ] perfect he's perfect
I know I had been keeping him in my
thoughts all this time I'm really good
at judging people I'm sure you are man
I mean your mom your mom she beat me
she's probably really proud of you know
yeah well I mean she's a fillip you know
mom and I feel like Asian moms are never
really happy and until you have a
diploma like us of something so I mean
yes for the most part she is proud but
she's always that constant reminder
she's like Brett you're not gonna be
famous forever if you don't know that
and then she's like yeah you have to go
to school and I'm like homegirl a let me
do this and then I'll go to school later
yeah school like you said Fame is not
forever but school she is and I can go
to come around 50 that's true but Brett
Menaul so let me say this all right
I've been working as a comedian and
actor since
I was 28 29 years old oh my god now 48
years old now and I'm still working so
it doesn't stop it's not gonna stop for
you okay
Oh either but you know Asian moms just
be like they put this hair of China in
you always I always say shut the [ __ ] up
mom you don't know you don't know man
I send your checks [ __ ] not the same
generation I know I know you know it's
so funny it's like you know the internet
what you know what it's like I'm so glad
for the internet because you know I
could discover people like you buddy
thank you and I swear to [ __ ] god man
if I go to Hawaii and I try to contact
you know you too [ __ ]